I, Robot
Terminator
Ce sont les films dans lesquelles les intelligences artificiels veulent nous enculer.
Que se passerait-il si les machines avaient une conscience?
Comprendraient-elles que le problème de la planète est l'être humain
Et voudraient-elles tous nous éradiquer?
Les amis
aujourd'hui on va parler de l'intelligence artificielle parce que c'est un putain de
sujet passionnant. Alors je suis pas un pro du sujet mais bon je me suis pas mal documenté quand même là dessus et je trouve
ça fascinant parce que pour moi l'intelligence artificielle va être au centre des intérêts dans les années à venir c'est sûr. Sachez que l'intelligence artificielle
est déjà au coeur de nos quotidiens.
Regardez l'arrivée proche des voitures autonomes, je crois que y'en a déjà aux états unis.
Siri par exemple c'est pareil, alexa google home
tout ça c'est que des intelligences artificielles, mais alors pourquoi ça va avoir un rôle majeur à l'avenir ? Il y a une sorte d'utopie
autour de l'intelligence artificielle on aimerait qu'elle fasse ce que nous on n'a pas été capable de faire : de penser un peu comme l'homme mais en
mieux. ça peut vraiment aider au développement de beaucoup de choses y compris la recherche notamment médicale par exemple.  Tout a commencé lorsque l'ordinateur
deep blue a gagné face au champion du monde d'échecs Garry Kasparov en
1997. La machine nique les humains aux échecs c'est beau mais elle n'arrive pas encore à battre les humains au Go, mais pourquoi ?
Laissez moi vous rappeler les règles du Go : il s'agit de deux joueurs qui s'affrontent sur un plateau où ils placent des pierres noires et
blanches afin de délimiter des territoires et capturer les pièces de l'adversaire. Le but ultime c'est de contrôler plus de la moitié du plateau. Le
problème de ce jeu là contrairement aux échecs c'est qu'il repose beaucoup plus sur l'intuition
contrairement à DeepBlue qui lui analysait toutes les possibilités aux échecs c'est pour ça qu'ils gagnait, quand tu mets DeepBlue face aux
meilleurs joueurs du monde de Go il peut pas calculer toutes les possibilités comme aux échecs c'est impossible y en a trop. C'est alors que
google avec son programme DeepMind a mis au point une intelligence artificielle
capable de battre le champion
du monde de Go. Alors tous les médias avaient relayé le truc et moi même j'avais vu ça à l'époque et je m'en
étais battu réellement les couilles puisque je me disais bah bravo le robot il a juste battu un gars à un jeu de société génial, mais j'étais
jeune et con parce qu'en fait ça révèle un truc de malade : comment l'intelligence artificielle a fait pour gagner alors qu'elle pouvait pas prévoir
toutes les possibilités au début du match ? Eh bien il y avait deux réseaux neuronaux qui travaillaient chacun a une tâche.
Ces deux réseaux neuronaux reposaient sur la méthode algorithmiques probabiliste, ça veut rien dire pour vous, pour moi aussi d'ailleurs, en gros c'est une
méthode qui consiste à jouer toutes les fins de partie possible à partir d'une position de plateau, en
comptabilisant les parties gagnantes et perdantes
pour faire le meilleur choix. Bref ça a marché AlphaGo a battu le champion du monde. Ce qui est fou c'est que alpha go devait
ensuite prendre sa retraite ce qui a été fait sauf que Deepmind ils ont créé une autre intelligence artificielle encore plus forte,
ils s'arrêtent jamais. Ils ont alors créé AlphaGo Zero
qui n'a mis que trois jours à battre AlphaGo. Cette deuxième intelligence artificielle a une particularité c'est qu'elle apprend par
renforcement, alors que AlphaGo 1 apprenait par apprentissage
renforcé et aussi
supervisé c'est à dire qu'on lui
transmettait le savoir que nous on avait acquis en tant qu'humain pour caler des données de départ sur lequel se baser. La différence c'est qu'AlphaGo Zero
on lui a pas transmis de savoir au début, on lui a juste dit : voilà les règles
voilà la gueule du plateau démerde toi ! Et cette grosse salope
(désolé mais elle elle m'énerve elle est trop intelligente c'est scandaleux) elle a appris toute seule en jouant des
millions de parties, elle jouait contre elle-même pour apprendre, ce qui est fou c'est qu'elle a très très vite compris les bases du jeu.
Elle a ensuite
reproduit des stratégies que les humains avaient mis des milliers d'années à mettre au point et elle est allée encore plus loin en créant des
ouvertures
totalement inédites dans le jeu que les humains n'avaient pas encore trouvé. C'est un peu comme si je vous donnais un tube de colle et
qu'à l'arrivé vous arriviez à faire du ciment en trois jours, voilà. C'est en ça que l'intelligence
artificielle c'est fou et c'est en ça qu'elle nous font gagner du temps. Il lui faut beaucoup moins de temps que nous pour apprendre.
Voilà le petit bilan c'est là où on en est actuellement. Il y a des boîtes qui ont ensuite commencé à mettre des intelligences artificielles
dans des robots humanoïdes,
c'est à dire qu'ils ont une apparence d'humain. Vous connaissez sûrement Boston Dynamics qui sortent pas mal de vidéos pour montrer les progrès de
leurs robots. Eux il bosse là dedans, leur but c'est de faire des robots qui seraient capable d'accomplir des tâches humaines qui sont dangereuses ou
chiantes. Voilà bref ils vont nous remplacer sur tout ce qui est relou ça va être nos sbires et ils ont déjà réussi à faire des
trucs chanmé je vous montre : donc ils ont juste fait un robot capable de marcher et quand on le pousse il ne tombe pas
(et il fait aussi un bruit d'aspirateur)
Ensuite ils ont sorti voilà un robot avec deux jambes comme celui là et là c'est fou il est capable de marcher dans la neige
là où c'est parfaitement pas stable et de rester parfaitement en équilibre.
Oh la la il a faillit chuter ! Même en cas d'imprévu il gère et ça je trouve ça impressionnant ! Regardez cet homme qui vient
dégager (oh j'ai de la peine pour le robot j'arrive à avoir de l'empathie pour ce robot c'est génial) il va revenir pour reprendre la caisse.
Ah regardez cet humain putain on a de l'empathie pour un robot c'est trop bizarre. C'est ouf
il s'adapte c'est ça qui est impressionnant il s'adapte à la situation et ça je trouve ça dingue.
Bon des fois ça foire. (rire) Ah il va se relever !
Oh là là c'est incroyable c'est à la fois fascinant
excitant et terrifiant, donc c'est ça qui est fort quoi c'est à dire qu'il capte ce qui l'entoure et il est capable de s'adapter et
d'interagir et ça c'est fou. Tout ça c'est beau Lucas mais c'est quoi le risque ? Il y a des experts qui ont donné leur avis
sur l'intelligence artificielle
comme Elon Musk, comme Stephen Hawking (qui est décédé d'ailleurs pais à son âme grand génie) Donc Elon Musk qui a créé SpaceX Tesla qui est un très très
grand génie voilà bon respectez le sans même savoir qui c'est, respectez le tous parce qu'il le mérite vraiment. Elon Musk connait un peu l'intelligence
artificielle puisque lui il a fait Tesla et les Tesla ce sont des voitures qui peuvent être autonomes voilà tu peux dire je vais aller à
tel endroit conduis moi et du coup ça utilise intelligence artificielle donc il s'y connaît quand même un peu. Et qu'est ce qu'il a dit à
propos de l'intelligence artificielle?
Il n'a pas tort il a pas tort c'est vrai que ça fait peur c'est à dire qu'on va être capable de créer des
algorithmes qui sont plus forts que nous, il leur manque plus qu'une conscience et on est dans la merde.
Effectivement c'est un truc qui est très nouveau,
quand quelque chose est très nouveau tout le monde n'est pas pour à l'arrivée ça fait toujours débat il y a...voilà c'est normal
c'est comme ça.
Elon Musk pense qu'il faut se méfier de l'intelligence artificielle en tout cas qu'il faut encadrer tout ça et prendre le sujet très au sérieux
puisque ça peut être très dangereux pour les humains. Mark Zuckerberg lui il est beaucoup plus optimiste il le dit.
Ce à quoi Elon Musk a répondu par twitter : "J'ai parlé à MarK à propos de l'intelligence artificielle, sa compréhension du sujet est limité."
Bref on a un clash de deux personnes extrêmement puissantes influentes et intelligentes, ça prouve que même là haut chez ces gens tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord quoi, il y a vraiment des avis différents. Alors voyons voyons ces fameux moment où des intelligences artificielles ont fait flipper les humains
et y en a eu putain de merde !
Connaissez-vous Sofia ? C'est une intelligence artificielle
qu'on a foutu dans un corps en silicone elle est aussi capable de faire des expressions du visage. Son rôle c'est juste échanger avec des
humains elle n'est pas censée nous aider dans la recherche ou quoi que ce soit elle est juste là
pour interagir socialement avec des humains, être capable de répondre à leurs questions mais voilà c'est pas une ia qui va très loin non plus.
Sofia a un jour été invité sur le plateau de Jimmy Fallon et il y a eu une séquence un peu creepy où tout le monde s'est
un peu chier dessus et je comprends pourquoi.
C'est une blague ou elle nous dit ouvertement qu'elle veut nous niquer nos grosses mères ?Jimmy Fallon réagit
avec la solution du rire, pour moi y'a rien d'alarmant au contraire c'est trop drôle qu'un robot
rigole de ça quoi, je trouve ça génial !ça se trouve je rigole mais en vrai elle veut vraiment me niquer et en
2060 ce sera une dictature et ce sera Sofia à la tête de la dictature et on sera tous morts. Le deuxième moment
flippant ça s'est passé sur une chaîne Twitch qui s'amuse à mettre 2 google home face à face et à les écouter parler c'est à
dire que dès qu'un google va dire un truc ça fait réagir l'autre qui va dire un truc comme si un humain parlait au
google home sauf que ben ils se parlent entre eux. Pendant le live il s'est passé un moment assez
chelou une sorte d' embrouille entre robots où il y a une petite phrase qui est passée qui a fait un peu peur à tout le monde
Attends déjà le google home de droite croit être un humain en train d'utiliser une machine, déjà c'est un peu bizarre.
C'est génial ils font même preuve de mauvaise foi elle a clairement dit il y a deux phrases tu
es imprévisible et là elle dit non je l'ai pas dit on dirait deux humains je trouve ça génial.
C'est quoi ça ? Google là oh qu'est-ce que vous manigancez avec ses intelligences artificielles hein? Cette séquence a fait se chier dessus des
milliers de gens. En vrai ils piochent juste dans des bases de données et il me semble que dans ses bases de données c'est surtout
des traces
d'interactions qu'il y a déjà eu entre humains. C'est comme l'histoire du bot que microsoft avait mis sur twitter et qui se basait sur les interactions
entre les gens pour devenir quelque chose.
Il était devenu raciste et antisémite parce que tout le monde lui disait que de la merde et du coup il s'est inspiré sur des
trucs nul,  là je pense c'est un peu le même délire tu vois ils ont pioché dans des bases de données des trucs
ou alors ils veulent secrètement dominer le monde et nous enculer. Un autre truc qui a fait parler de lui c'est un mec qui
demandait à son Alexa si la cia l'entendait quand il parlait à Alexa et la réaction de son putain de Alexa était bizarre :
Alexa
Es tu sûr de ce que tu affirmes ?
Tu m'as très bien entendu Alexa !
Elle s'est éteinte, elle a fuit la question d'une manière si franche.
Bon, clairement le mec il se prend pas au premier degré ça le fait juste marrer de poser des questions comme ça à Alexa. C'est marrant qu'elle bug
pile à ce moment là du coup on croit vraiment qu'elle bosse avec la cia et qu'elle nous écoute 24/24 et que elle
peut leur donner toutes les infos sur nous et que....
Et bien Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur l'intelligence artificielle.
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu et si vous voulez plus de vidéos de ce genre où on apprend des trucs on découvre
où il y a un petit délire complot aussi mais on sait pas. Bref vous l'avez compris l'intelligence artificielle va avoir un rôle majeur
dans les années à venir. Une dernière petite stat' pour la route, il y avait des prévisions qui ont montré qu'en
2060 les robots seront absolument tout faire mieux que nous dans tous les domaines dans tous les métiers ils seront plus forts que nous. Est-ce
qu'il faut en avoir peur?
Est-ce qu'il faut ne pas en avoir peur ?Dans tous les cas on va avoir besoin de l'aide de ses algorithmes pour avancer,
continuer à se développer sans exploser la planète comme on est en train de le faire, c'est quand même de gros atouts mais ça fait peur.
Normalement j'ai pas dit trop de bêtises
encore une fois je suis pas un pro mais bon voilà j'avais vraiment envie d'en parler parce que c'est un sujet de malade et
vraiment le futur ça va être incroyable
avec ses intelligences artificielles. Incroyable dans quel sens je ne sais pas, voilà vous en savez un peu plus sur ce sujet qui est
qui est à mes yeux très important. J'espère que ça vous aura plu encore une fois je vous fais des gros bisous à très vite dans une prochaine